[Music]
it is here week 1 of the NFL season get
up off of your feet right now let's go
I can barely contain myself Thursday
night bears-packers Sunday in an
ornament amount of games two games on
Monday night the NFL season has arrived
I was gonna do all this wow stuff and I
don't even care anymore because anymore
it's not the season it's this season the
I'm gonna say that we are recording this
Tuesday at 2:30 and I said it because I
don't know what's happening with Zeke
right now so I'm not sure if the Zeke
deal is gonna get done today if get done
tomorrow oh we got Florio out here
tweeting out unconfirmed stories which
is just a beautiful thing the one thing
I do have confirmed ditch the playbook
hashtag D the P starts on Wednesday
episode comes out at 11:00 and it's
gonna be Mohamed Sanu how many
quarterbacks can he throw farther then
very excited in BER and I you're happy
with it I'm so happy with it Mike my
question to you when we showed up to the
episode how many did you think he could
throw farther than of the 32 starting
quarterback so let's not give away the
actual answer but right you think he
could do 16 yeah you would have been
happy if he was half if he made it
halfway through so you'll have to tune
in to see what he actually did so here's
what I want to do I want to take over
social so here's what I need if you're
listening this Wednesday morning get
ready if you listen to this podcast
Wednesday night jump on in what I want
you guys to do is I'm gonna tweet it out
Bleacher Report's gonna tweet it out if
you do it from mine I'll definitely see
it retweet it with the phrase this
episode is so good that and then write
something in there I like this
if you do that I am retweeting it one a
hundred percent so if you retweet my
tweet that's
here's this a new episode with this
episode is so good that and then have
something funny
I'm retweeting all of them right I want
this to spread it's gonna be we're gonna
have an episode this week an episode
next week and then after that it's gonna
be every other week and we are seven of
eight shot mm-hmm and they're all
awesome but I'm really happy with all of
them for the the tweets that are they're
so good that X you're still gonna read
them before you retweet them it's not a
bot that you've got cuz then that's been
like the weird vulgar stuff starts
happening no and it's only like for like
actual you can tell the line come right
up to the left go the human with an
actual human brain they'll be reading
these things and then deciding and if
there are if there are some that make me
laugh out loud I'm gonna read about next
week Spock everything is together I
don't know if you guys have noticed this
but like ditch the playbook I mean I
want to give another shout out for help
it out with ditch the playbook his name
is Vincent I just want to get his name
definitely correct one second Vincent
would Jaya he has done he did the
artwork on the social before about me
and Bart and Ernie and Charles sitting
on the couch shout out to this dude I
posted it on the left go show Instagram
people that help out this show I want to
help you guys out so rod Simba we're
gonna have new music from rod Simba
coming up on Thursday excuse me on
Friday which is gonna be the first
Warren sharp bedding podcast I have a
theme song that rod Simba made for
Warren that Warren hasn't heard yet and
it's awesome I almost want to play it
for you guys now but I don't want Warren
to hear it so we're gonna save it for
Friday by the way we are likely gonna be
having another co-host starting next
week for Monday and Wednesday candidly a
lot of contract stuff way above my pay
grade
I don't know what's going on I just want
it to happen already but we got Warren
and all signs are pointing to having
another person on next week so excited
but thank you
for your support as always I want to
give a shout out now I'm gonna do a
little video this is William ezel who
was running our fantasy league I made
him a deal here's here's what I always
say to the homies the 33% you guys get
me stuff I'll give you stuff back
because it's it's fair and it's not
gonna say balance but this is the
Commissioner of the LF GL al the left go
fantasy gridiron League the let's
[ __ ] go League he said I want to do
weekly updates I said all right man I
got you so here is the first weekly LF
GL update from William and all 1104 of
you for making this possible you made my
job easy as it could have been and made
all the traffic smooth but the real home
he goes out there bricks
0:08 who drafted six quarterbacks no
running back since no productive fifth
in the league you're the fan co me the
week good luck to everyone a week one
and may your expeditions go super high
so on week four and there one and three
they go crashing down good luck a big
one awesome job use video so that's he's
gonna highlight the fantasy homie of the
week I don't know if that's gonna be
every week or just this week but bold
strategy cotton six quarterbacks no
running back look I mean if those first
five quarterbacks get injured he's gonna
look like a genius
oh he's gonna feel great I want to know
who the quarterbacks were I also want to
know if he went first six picks in his
league had to him and if in the draft
you're like oh you went in the homes
first alright a little risky but I get
it deshaun Watson second round
Aaron Ryan yeah I wonder if the other
people in his league
we're like I need to get a quarterback
right now or else this guy Baxter is
gonna take all of them I love it
awesome job ezel eleven hundred and four
so awesome unbelievable a significant
portion of the US population at that
point I mean it feels like all of them
and any of them probably could have been
a better GM than the Houston Texans
what a weekend this was a lot of roster
formation so we're I'm gonna be breaking
down with Warren all most of the games
if not all of the games against the
spread I'm gonna be making my super
contest bets Friday is gonna be the big
betting episode at the end of this
episode I am gonna be making my
bears-packers pick because I do want you
guys to have that before a Thursday
night and then Warren can kind of hold
comment cuz we're gonna be recording
before that game but I'll break down
that game but roster formation this past
weekend with waivers cuts trades all of
that it shows you a lot of where teams
are and I have some nuggets and notes
but he easily hands down the Texan stole
the weekend with all of their moves the
first move that happened Seattle traded
for Jadeveon Clowney mm-hmm and I want
to break this down seriously first just
because the trade was Seattle got
Jadeveon Clowney Texans got Barkevious
Mingo Jacob Martin and a third-round
pick in next year's draft Jadeveon
Clowney was interviewed later and said
actually this during this offseason he
was talking to Dwayne brown now Seattle
left tackle former Texans offensive
tackle and pretty much said you know
what's it like up in Seattle heard it
was great and was like i'ma try and get
up there my first thought went that's
some NBA [ __ ] right there mm-hmm that's
some NBA stuff where like NFL players if
we start getting to this point where
we're right before hold or during a
holdout or right before that franchise
tag and you start communicating with the
other guys it's an interesting movement
there it's like Kevin Durant Kyrie
Irving at last year's all-star game just
like got caught on cameras in the
hallway like let's do this let's just
get together man we got this where the
two guys are gonna lead it to the future
thousand percent second thing I thought
was does this [ __ ] me over for my
Seahawks not making the playoffs pic and
so I went I looked at the Seahawks
roster and right now it is so insanely
necessary what they needed
in their first six weeks they for the
teams are Pittsburgh New Orleans Rams
Browns offense offense offense offense
and they were coming into the year with
Geron read suspended Ziggy Ansah and LJ
Collier banged up in pune fort this was
not a luxury for seattle they had to get
this guy all reports are that clown he's
in the best shape of his life which whoa
big first week i think that this is very
big for the seahawks for sort of buying
time early in the season for when Geron
reed and everybody comes back this is a
huge trade for for this also because i
look at their secondary right now and
I'm not that confident in their
secondary but I look at this the
Seahawks and I still have him right on
the fringe it was not enough for me to
put them in I will say having looked at
the rosters the two teams that I have in
the NFC playoffs that I feel the least
confident in are the Rams and the
Packers this to me brings the Seahawks a
lot closer to the Rams I'll get into my
roster building later but I looked at
the Rams and I was so surprised at how
shallow they are they are not deep at
all when you get to the Rams if they
start getting big injuries to people
they're gonna be in trouble
Seahawks get big depth not in my playoff
picture right now but I think it's a
huge move for the Seahawks to this might
be a one game push to get them in the
playoffs later I'll talk about the
Texans after that the Seahawks just so
you know Vegas does agree with you
there's a little bump in there sweet
awesome
I went from 32 1 to drumroll please let
me say 26 to 128 to 1 so not much of a
difference but there clearly was a
little bit of betting movement in there
that some folks in Vegas we're saying
hey you know what let me throw a little
flyer on the Seahawks they just beefed
up their defense a little bit absolutely
and it make sense to me because I think
that for the first time in a while I
actually kind of liked the offensive
line
Seahawks and I believe all of this the
the quotes about Brian Schottenheimer
throwing two running backs Moore and
Warren will be able to comment that
later my fear for them is it's Tyler
Lockett and a bunch of rookies and
people that I've never heard of at wide
receiver
yeah losing Doug Baldwin was actually a
bigger deal than I think people are
talking about Norma's huge huge safety
blanket type receiver for him and I know
that people were feeling their defense
but I'll not that shirt on him yet
then it got crazy then the Texans start
dealing with the Dolphins and they trade
for Laremy Tunsil I am actually a
big-time fan of this
I am perspective okay yeah really from
both perspective well they picked up a
franchise left tackle and I'm not a huge
like know everything about the trenches
type of football player so I really
looked into Laremy Tunsil his Laremy
Tunsil here he's played 45 of his 48
possible games in this career he's 25
years old making him one of only two
players under the age of 28 in terms of
the top 10 left tackles as as graded by
Madden this year which you know is as
good of a metric as anything sure this
is this guy hit easily and some of the
guys that are in the top 10 we're
talking like the Joe staleys type
they're 35 37 years old within three or
four years Laremy Tunsil might be a top
three left tackle in the game which is
arguably the most important position
when you got a franchise quarterback
like - Shaun Watson also when you factor
in that
deshaun Watson has been hit in an insane
amount of times when you factor in the
fact that deshaun Watson had rib and
lung injuries last year and had to
travel to Jacksonville on buss because
he couldn't fly that's how banged up he
was right when you factor in that their
offensive line cording to Brandon thorn
was 31st in the NFL and you just saw
your AFC South enemy Andrew Luck retire
at 29 what they did was by bringing in
Laremy Tunsil you have Laremy Tunsil
your left tackle the future now they're
gonna have to pay him an amount of money
that's obscene
because he owns all of the cards in that
negotiation you just went out and you
drafted Titus Howard a max scharping and
I expect them to play a lot at guard
you now have a young up-and-coming with
talent offensive line you also in that
trade for the Texans get Kenny Stills
who I don't know if you guys been paying
attention their slot their slot wide
receiver Kiki Cote very talented has
been a hurt off and on for his entire
career right now so now you have Hopkins
fuller stills in my mind up there four
top top seven might even be top five in
terms of receiver in terms of wide
receiver trios in the NFL that they also
trade for Carlos Hyde when I realized
though is Bill O'Brien is on the hot
seat he's on the hot seat for a number
of reasons one he's on the hot seat cuz
I don't think they've been that
successful
he's on the hot seat too because he's
going to be getting a new GM next year
and the GM is gonna come in and gonna go
I have to re-evaluate everything but
also he's an offensive mind so what did
he do Bill O'Brien sold his one of his
best offensive players to get better on
offense the Houston Texans I was already
thinking they were gonna have to be a
shootout team this year because when you
look at who they've lost they lost honey
badger at safety
they let Kareem Jackson go in free
agency now they trade you Davian clowny
I mean that's three other best I would
argue that they're right up there with
JJ Watt cuz JJ Watt with his injuries in
his age so now I look at the Texans one
I'm betting the over on every Texans
game this year especially for the first
two we know yeah 35 30 I think that's
what they're aiming for those types of
games but to me this is Bill O'Brien
putting Romeo Crennel on the hot seat
and going hey new GM we had a top-five
offense in the NFL last year granted our
bottom our defense was bottom five but
that's Romeo Crennel and maybe we just
get a new defensive coordinator and he's
just hoping that in the
post-season negotiations people will
have forgotten what what the reasons
were for that yet yeah because what
happens is at the end of the year we go
well they were second in offense last
year yeah well what the and Bill
O'Brien's the one making all these calls
and it's clear he is because he has no
regard for the salary cap to cut Matt
Khalil and just eat two and a half
million dollars to trade you Devi and
clowny and still pay seven million
dollars but I don't know what's going on
right now in that front office it's a
question that everybody's asking right
but this again we're gonna go cross
sport analogies this happens with
basketball all the time where some GM
makes a Hail Mary type move and they say
if it works out I'm a genius if it
doesn't work out I'm not gonna be here
so I'm gonna get fired when these pics
come to fruition you know when we've
traded like you know the pics in 2021 in
2023 in 2025 I will be long gone by all
that time and haha the schmuck that
takes over my job he'll clean up that
mess ha ha ha look linette's yeah ok
exactly I'll be the athletic director at
like Notre Dame by then who cares so I
said that I love the trade for Laremy
Tunsil I look any time you give up to
first-round picks I do not love it any
time you trade for a franchise left
tackle that's coming up on a contract
here and you don't have a new deal done
I don't love it but the idea of
protecting deshaun Watson and and the
thing is as Miami's in full tank full
tank and so for them to have two
first-round picks
extra the next two years they've made a
number of trades this offseason
I support the Dolphins going full Sixers
I support the Dolphins going full
process they don't have a quarterback do
exactly what the Browns did fill all of
the roster spots around him maybe not
even draft to it this year maybe draft
your quarterback in two years like the
Browns did where they wouldn't had that
one - Shaun Kaiser year but it was
really to draft more really good guys
for when you eventually draft Baker be
smart be smart I get it
but from the Texans I do like aligning a
25 year old franchise tackle and like a
20
three-year-old deshaun Watson and having
those guys set for life because Hopkins
is your guy I get it but it really looks
like to me that Bill O'Brien is selling
his defense down the river so that when
the new GM comes in likely Nick Kesari
oh he can go but my offense was great my
offense was killing it out there because
when deshaun Watson in those pockets
when he's been healthy and been
relatively protected that team puts up
points Oh puts up points I mean that
he's just he's a guy that when he's when
he's in his groove he's putting up
points along the lines of the Matt
Ryan's and the Drew Brees isn't anyone
else that you'd want in the league and
just a quick reminder another reason why
I'm gonna be betting the over in almost
every Houston Texans game until Vegas
realizes hey I was gonna say the lines
will catch up
the Texans face the 11th softest pass
defense so now he's got a left tackle
even more safe yeah and they face the
third toughest offenses all year so that
team that just traded up Jadeveon
Clowney and I'm telling you I'm looking
at their linebackers and stuff bro it's
it's it's a bunch of rookies and they're
gonna have to play Barkevious Mingo and
Jacob Martin like they had to trade also
for Kia and Casson at corner this this
Tex and defense is going down and that
offense is going up the big question
that everyone is wondering is what the
hell was happening though in the front
office in Houston and what's pretty
incredible is David you actually got
ahold of some phone transcripts yeah
there are some sources out there you
know when I started working here at
bleacher report I you know I got in
touch with some folks and like got some
doodles around yeah it's got some
contacts around the league and once in a
while people will send me some you know
some pretty like juicy nuggets of
information this is the juiciest one
we've gotten so far yeah this isn't even
just words this is this is audio this is
the actual write this is the actual
phone call between interim GM of the
Texans Chris Olson
yeah and Schneider from from Seattle
John Schneider the other GM of Seattle
let's uh let's let's take a listen ok
hello Houston Texans interim general
manager / parking lot
attending Chris Olson speaking how can I
help you uh hey it's John Schneider I
didn't realize you answered your own
phone I literally just googled front
office phone number for the Texas
yeah we're short-staffed these days yeah
my assistant and my intern actually both
just got hired by the Patriots it's been
a wild summer man okay well well I got
you Chris
I was wonder if we could talk a trade
for Jadeveon Clowney what I trade what
do you what do you mean I don't think
I'm authorized to make those kinds of
decisions what a kind of decisions you
mean trades aren't you the GM yes
technically but I generally manage the
vending machines not the team coach bill
doesn't let be it doesn't let me meereee
the roster okay well then let me ask you
this would you rather have two really
good players or one really good player
well when you phrase it like that to I
guess would exactly and what if you only
had to pay half of this salary oh well
that sounds like one hell of a deal but
we have to do it fast because I do have
to go gas up the team bus oh god I feel
so alive right now making trades adding
red vines to the vending machines I want
to make more trades hello it's Chris
Olson yeah well we'll literally trade
anything for your best player who is
this hey it's Chris Grier from the
Dolphins
we're looking to shop Laremy Tunsil
great house forty first-round picks and
my first child
no All My Children and Deshawn Watson's
unborn children and my second round
picks okay I was gonna ask for a salary
cap relief but sure let's do it I'm
drunk with power and that is inside the
tank I don't know how you got that
footage look I'm just so glad it was
from an anonymous it was anonymous we're
so much I sound like John Schneider and
Chris Greer yeah it's weird people have
pointed out that I sound like interim GM
Chris Olson yeah I didn't hear it before
but now just having heard that it's like
it's actually uncanny that's pretty
unbelievable but anyway if you guys work
for the teams out there we're hopefully
we'd love to air more yes the phone
calls throughout the season so if you
have more stuff like this just email it
to me yeah email email we're always
looking for sources we're always looking
for moles so this is a full an
advertisement for that I will say this
about the Texan situation it is for
that dude is the interim GM but I do
think the interesting thing is is there
was this guy that came from the Patriots
to the Texans he was also like the team
chaplain Jack Easter be this is what I'm
talking about these these multi / - it's
like the Kordell Stewart at the front
office okay so of the four characters
and I compared them to succession I
think I've talked about it before
Jack East Herbie was the character coach
for the Patriots when they went through
their Aaron Hernandez stuff right he was
the one dealing with all the players
when they were going through the and
apparently the final straw was the
Robert Kraft massage parlor thing that's
when he quit and went to the Texans but
here's what's interesting about old Jack
Easter B people describe him as
power-hungry people say that he started
off as just a guy that would listen to
Bill and started working his way up like
he is like kind of Tom from succession
oh oh yeah he didn't think much of him
in season one but all this all of a
sudden he starts getting power and so
the interesting thing with this Jack
Easter B guy is he's making a run at
this GM thing ah he was the guy the
character coach that would also a former
team chaplain like just doesn't this
sound weird I can't possibly be a normal
trajectory for front office guys to go
from team chaplain slash career just
every important person he's a little bit
like in Silicon Valley the guy that
helps out like the weird chakra guy oh
sure the Guru yes yes the Guru he just
he hitches himself to the right wagon
and all of a sudden manager like what
the hell
that's this Jack Easter B guy he's one
of the four I think
everyone out there listening that's in
the workforce right now can point to at
least three people that they do or have
worked with who doesn't deserve the
immense amount of success but they
happen to be friends with the right
person at the right time and you're like
yeah I guess this happens to the NFL
front office's do by the way you know
who the Texans face in week one with
this new decimated defense I just looked
it up who is it at New Orleans on Monday
Night Football because Drew Brees and
Sean Payton are gonna take it easy on
them mm-hmm just saying yeah yeah
they're not pissed off they didn't spend
the offseason trying to think like how
we're gonna hang up
50 points in our opener yes so that'll
be very interesting other news and notes
just of the weekend
LeSean McCoy goes to the Chiefs if you
have Damian Williams you are in fantasy
you're pissed I have Darwin Thompson and
I'm pissed but it's it's gonna be a
three-headed backfield football wise
Sammy Watkins Tyree kill McCole Hardman
Travis Kelce Robinson now LeSean McCoy
Williams Patrick mahomes the Chiefs
offense is gonna be unbelievable it's
just a lot of touchdowns up for grabs
I've it's from fantasy you you're kind
of hoping people get hurt we will never
hope that that happens it's almost like
from a fantasy perspective it's almost
like too many guys exactly what it is
yeah it's like obviously we we know
Travis Kelce is pretty much the
consensus number one tight end but if
you're gonna he'll see and he'll are
safe but if you had any of those running
backs their value just plummet yeah you
just have no idea who's gonna get the
Arend zone
Sammy Watkins all of those guys go down
a notch but Hill and Kelsey are
Untouchables but for them as a as a
football team I had a lot of questions
about Damian Williams look he was great
in the playoffs he has never had
sustained success for a long period of
time
Darwyn Thompson is an exciting rookie
but LeSean McCoy is a legitimate veteran
that has experience and if they if
either of them get hurt now what's a
solid backup and and I think it's an
unbelievable pickup they paid good money
for him I think the other news that came
out that people weren't talking about
their main competition was the Chargers
they were like we got to get LaShawn in
order to keep him from the Chargers as
much as we want him on our own roster
not even that I thought it also opened
this the Chargers came out this weekend
and said Melvin Gordon you're allowed to
look for a trade I see wow this is a
Machiavellian stuff Melvin they also
came out and said under no circumstance
will we give Melvin Gordon a new
contract but they were trying to get
LeSean McCoy right so while the Chargers
are going out and saying we are more
than willing to go into this season with
Austin Eckler and Justin Jackson
they were knocking down the door of
LeSean McCoy to try and get him there so
the Chiefs offered him four million
dollars guaranteed the Chargers don't
get him and I'm just sitting here going
man that um I am now other than the fact
that I don't the Chargers making the
playoffs I am rooting on the Chargers
offense to start slow because I want
Melvin Gordon has no leverage at all the
only leverage he can get is if the
charger starts low and I just found it
very interesting that they felt the need
to go after LeSean McCoy right and it's
a lot it's a lot easier to say like hey
we don't need you Melvin Gordon if we've
got shady McCoy in our back the only
other nugget that I'll get they'll give
because people will forget head coach of
the Chargers Anthony Lynn one of LeSean
McCoy best years ever was when Anthony
Lynn was the offensive coordinator for
the Bills two years ago and that was
what got Anthony Lynn the job so that's
the only the only other reason they have
a connection there his LeSean was
choosing between his former OC and his
former head coach Danny Reed but I still
think it's very telling and speaking of
the bills if you picked up Devin
Singletary at the end of your fantasy
draft as I did I had no idea this was
gonna be this much of a boon this early
but I feel like we've talked about this
in the podcast before I'm a big believer
in preseason if not your productivity
but the assignments that you get and I
felt like the bills were putting Devin
Singletary in positions to say you might
be part of our offense here and the fact
that they were willing to part with
LeSean McCoy this early on before the
season even starts they might be saying
Devin Singletary could be part of our
offense a major part of our offense
this whole year I'm gonna rain on your
fantasy be really great do it I want to
feel like [ __ ] I have a feeling that
it's gonna be a lot of Frank Gore early
because that's when you get Frank Gore
and his medium and then it goes away my
only concern about Devin Singletary is
TJ Yeldon is still on the roster and I'm
curious because TJ Yeldon is supposed to
be also that third down back so I feel
like have Singletary on your bench the
first few weeks you're gonna go what the
[ __ ] and then if you had now if there's
a lot of injuries and you got to make
moves I'm sorry
running back deadlines are a bad idea
ever and you might have to wait that out
a little bit and that's fine right yeah
I got James Connor and Chris Carson
ready to go I'm just saying like it's
it's a good pickup now or
betrayed for him while he might have
some low value but I believe in Devin
Singletary Florida Atlantic Lee what do
you think journalistically and I'm a
retired journalist of Mike Florio
tweeting out Zeke cut excuse me
Ezekiel Elliott contract six 490 million
unconfirmed I don't have that confirm
what do you think about putting out news
and then saying that news is unconfirmed
yeah I think that's a weird thing to do
but um this is this is the position that
we as fans and consumers have put
journalists into right if we didn't care
that whenever was your chef door glaze
or one of these people whenever they put
out an unconfirmed reports if we didn't
care they wouldn't keep doing it when do
they ever put out on confirm reports
what I'm saying is they don't think we
get tweets all the time they're sort of
like I've semi heard something know what
Adam Schefter tweets out the Cowboys and
Zeke are very close they're hoping to
get something done the next 48 hours
that's information but shefter has never
gone the Cowboys and Zeke are looking at
this this terms of contract
och I don't have a confirm so you think
this was someone leaking from the front
office or someone leaking from Zeke's
can this is Florio hearing something and
going I want to be the one that reported
this so I'm going to use one person's
information the all of these reporters
have information it's who has more than
one source from the team and the player
who or who has it from the player who
has it from Jerry Jones but if you have
an ancillary character and then you're
gonna use those numbers and then later
you get to play both sides of the coin
if it ends up being around there I'm the
man I got it and if it ends up not was
unconfirmed it must have changed yeah I
think with with sports because there
aren't lives at stake I think it's more
fun and more okay to tweet out
unconfirmed reports as long as you call
them as such and then you fess up like a
real adult humor was interesting about
Zeke is two days ago
Charles Robinson of U of Yahoo on Sunday
I guess tweeted out they are really
really really close it's going to happen
but and he had another word in there to
he's like I'm not sure
and so it's these reporters hedging
their bets the problem is this when
watch tweets its fact and that's why
it's a woge bum when shefter tweets its
fact Glaser's up there too it's this
second and third team news breaker guys
that are trying to get up to their level
that are so afraid of the dark cloud
that is those guys because they're so
unstoppable that I don't I don't need
you tweeting because dude my phone blew
up everybody's hit me up oh six ninety
six ninety OHS Ebola and the thing is is
it's not done yet this deal we're
recording at Tuesday at three o'clock
and I'll wait and see if my phone
explodes this might not get done I I
just read something it might not get
done till next week Zeke might not play
this weekend so now he's just sent off
it's just it's annoying to me because
while it's not as important as news and
while it's not as important as weather
and all that stuff and how it impacts
people's safety at the same point this
is my [ __ ] world
everyone's getting paid in an ornament
amount of money to cover this sport and
it paid all that stuff there are billion
dollar industries and I would also say
this as betting starts to get legal
right what if that changed the [ __ ]
number there will be repercussions to
this information later when when when
billions of dollars start really getting
put into injury reports and Vegas when
this and the league gets involved that
hearing that Zeek is good today is gonna
shift the Cowboys line by a point and a
half hour it will change the line yeah
and so I'm curious down the road how
much that's gonna impact those let's so
what what is your proposed solution then
because there needs to be repercussions
like like the the journalistic outlets
that are that these guys are working for
they need to have some sort of penalty
box my thing because if you if you're
willing to work for two weeks yeah you
guys for two weeks yeah Twitter shuts
you down for a month or whatever it is
that's got to be some sort of penalty
box because it should be punitive they
should they should be weighing the risk
and reward and the right now the only
the reward is hey this guy was on at
first which is actually like gold in the
journalistic world the risk is that some
people go that guy's not that
trustworthy and the next time they send
something else that's unconfirmed people
might say oh this guy was lying
timer was full of [ __ ] last time so that
is a risk that is a legit risk that
they're taking on but I think people
have a tendency to forget those times
when we were wrong just because we're
bombarded by so many tweets from so we
just worth everything maybe we just want
all that we want all of it we love
rumors love the rumors and and I look
I'm not saying this that Florio Florio
should get in trouble for this because
it might get done today who the hell
knows I just I just think it's there
will be really believed with gambling
there will be a lot more repercussions
to this stuff and what's to stop you
because here's what I'm saying like I
think what you're about to say what's to
stop me from a gambling conglomerate
writing up to me and saying I want that
number right now the Cowboys I have not
looked at the lines it'll [ __ ] me up if
I look at the lines the Cowboys are
favored by three I want C to come back
it'll push it down it'll push it up to
five and I want that number that's what
I'm saying cuz these that's what I'm
saying these billion-dollar
conglomerates could have tentacles
everywhere what like you Adam left go
you're a guy that knows NFL players you
hang out with these guys they know you
they tweeted that Bryce Harper was going
to get a contract and like a lot of
people ran with it
that and and guess what it happened that
day and he got it done cuz I did have a
source on the Bryce Harper contract at
the same point I'm sitting there going
why don't I just do this all the time
you could slightly move things right but
yeah there's it there's there's an a
responsibility that does come along with
being a person in the media some people
take that responsibility very seriously
sometimes there are a little bit more
lacks a little more loosey-goosey with
it and that's that's the problem but
that's what's something we've been
dealing with me age of the internet for
20 years now but Zeke will get a deal
done so he will be playing either he
will be having a deal done this season
you have a source or this is just your
feel for things oh no like my feel for
things as Zeke is either gonna be good
this week or next week and I still don't
think Melvin Gordon's coming back this
season yeah I'm getting more and more
emboldened in the confidence of that
stuff right now but that's kind of where
we are men but I just sometimes I put
all my old journalist hat and I look at
him like I've never seen someone tweet
out information as unconfirmed like you
don't tweet that out but that's just me
being an old stickler six years 490
Millions that's 15 million exact today
those numbers don't matter to me
until I see until I see the guaranteed
money that's all pretend yeah it is it's
all monopoly money but I did think it
was interesting they also signed Lyle
Collins which opened up some money for
this year and then Jerry came out and
said I'm running out of pie I don't have
enough paths for everybody
well then maybe stop signing offensive
linemen and defensive linemen and
linebackers when you have a quarterback
running back and wide receiver out but I
don't know who am I so I went through
everybody's Raught do you have any other
thing on any of those topics that you
want to talk about oh yeah we did just
jump past the the Laremy Tunsil yeah
when he left it just it made the Miami
Dolphins offensive line worse and
getting rid of a top-tier left tackle
just in case Josh Rosen gets thrown into
the fire again you know like he might be
one of these guys that could have been
really good in the right situation when
he or someone got pummeled in Arizona
last year and he could have been great
if he was in the right situation the
Dolphins had the 32nd ranked offensive
line and they lose Laremy Tunsil
with Laremy Tunsil right so now they
lose him yeah it's not at a 36th rank so
Josh Rosen goes from Arizona with a
coach fired in his first season with an
offensive line completely depleted under
attack goes to Miami new coach offensive
line they trade everybody away they get
they trade his number one wide receiver
and his left tackle they're like good
luck kid
now Ryan Fitzpatrick starting how do you
think Ryan Fitzpatrick and Josh Rosen
took the news cuz I feel like they took
it completely different I think Josh
Rosen woke up and he you know had a
bunch of text from his friends that were
like do they just traded your top left
left tackle and he's like oh I didn't
realize that all of 2018 was a dream I
just got drafted I'm playing for Arizona
again he's having like a Groundhog Day
situation and I feel like Ryan
Fitzpatrick is like I have to scramble
more you think he's excited you need me
to run around more oh this is it guys
and like like I don't know man he's got
the beard he's got the speed beard
that's that beards aerodynamic actually
people don't know that I just I I think
Fitzpatrick's kind of like you know what
this team is tanking
they might need me to be the starter for
the next two years I'm the perfect tank
quarterback I I think in a weird way
Fitzpatrick like Rosen's sitting there
in like if there was hard knocks for
dolphins Rosen's sitting there going are
you [ __ ] kidding me man like every
year like what the hell is going on and
Fitzpatrick's like man we'll figure it
out I use the roof Fitzpatrick has
settled into a really cool lane which is
like I'm gonna get you a couple of
spectacular September and October
performances you know you can guarantee
that I'm gonna get like five to six wins
if you leave me out there I'm gonna [ __ ]
the bed a couple of times but you know
what I'm always good for 14 or 15 starts
if you need me now if you don't need me
I'm happy to chill on the bench too and
let the young can eat hot dogs that's a
great lane you know who the Dolphins
play week one god I keep forgetting I
literally can never keep all tomorrow
Ravens oh yeah they're gonna get juice
it's it's it's unbelievable can I also
share with you my favorite Dolphins
tweet oh yeah yeah yeah this is from
Chris Syria I think he's a media guy so
the Dolphins sent out a 20-19 calendar
to all their season ticket holders right
there were 12 people featured on the
calendar obviously only four of them are
still with the team this is the 2019
calendar so Parker Drake Jones and
Harris are the only guys that are the
survivors and gone from the calendar we
got wake Phillip Tankersley Branch
McDonald Alonso Tannehill any stills
that's wild so yeah imagine just like in
January you're like here's our team baby
here's our 12 marquee guys and
two-thirds of them are gone before week
one speaking of media and stuff there's
a big thing right now about the teams
that Melvin Gordon is following on
social he's followed like the Niners the
Eagles like a few other teams and I love
how that's becoming reporting now to a
lot of I emojis like mm oh yeah and and
then I just got a text in my group chat
that says was Melvin Gordon in
Conshohocken this past weekend I'm just
gonna tell you that Melvin Gordon was
not in Conshohocken pencil me it's a
really good it might be an onion type of
artic you and I might have been in
Conshohocken Pennsylvania last weekend I
don't know all right so a few other
roster notes that I got just from
looking at how GM's and coaches built
their roster
number one the Cardinals and the
Dolphins have five guys on their rosters
each that they claimed off waivers this
does not include other signings which
means nearly 10% of the Cardinals and
Dolphins rosters got there yesterday
think about that there are teams like
the the Rams and the Eagles had like
four guys that they cut claimed so like
they couldn't even like they had too
many guys meanwhile the Dolphins and the
Cardinals they it's like rate waivers
and rookies though that's a sure sign
that like Miami look you're going full
process but Arizona you have two guys in
your front office that have been
arrested for drunk driving okay
and now like we're the the Cardinals
were not in a rebuild they just sucked
out of nowhere they hired a new coach
and said this is the guy claiming five
guys off waivers is an insane amount of
guys I'm always fascinated by which guys
need time with the PlayBook and which
ones don't
I remember when Allen Iverson got traded
to Denver like a on a Thursday and he
was on the team on a Friday starting I
was [ __ ] I know basketball is
different than football
like I'm curious like with Ezekiel
Elliott you know like is it just like
alright this time you run left this time
you run right actually saw so because
their defensive coordinator excuse me
their offensive coordinator is going to
be using a very similar playbook Kellen
Moore former quarterback for them
apparently it's everything that Zeke's
already known which to me everyone's
like oh that's positive we'll join in I
go timeout you guys were selling me all
offseason that Kelly Mohr's gonna bring
in a new offense what are the other guys
and now you're telling me that Zeke
doesn't need to learn anything new
before week one that now I'm like I'm
excited for Zeke but I'm worried about
this Dallas offense and I'm very curious
just like what would be the hierarchy in
terms of obviously needs time with the
PlayBook and needs time with the with
the offense for precision and timing I
assume a running back would be up there
in terms of like exactly where to stand
exactly what it take this thing
everything that I've always heard from
guys I've talked to defensive lineman is
the easiest okay it's get the [ __ ]
quarter but yeah yeah tackle the ball
offensive linemen it gets very tricky
because there's a lot of pulls and traps
and timing like you said
um running back is actually a lot easier
than wide receiver tight end is tough
because there's blocking right secondary
it depends it also depends on whether or
not you were doing a system that's
similar because the thing that you
always hear is it's different verbage so
the words are different but the schemes
are always similar but quarterback is
obviously the hardest but running back
should be easy it's I'd like to think so
I go back to that bill Barnwell thing
where he talks about sometimes it's
tough to know when you're dealing with
like the secondary you're trying to
appraise a certain player in the
secondary did he score well on sale or
was he supposed to actually run up on
the ball and he did exactly what he were
supposed to do and he just got beat
because some other guy didn't come over
this high issue all the time with Pro
Football Focus when they they have
grades out for secondary guys and the
film hasn't come out yet
right I'm going to fall game I can't
even see the safeties on the screen for
90% of the game how the [ __ ] do you know
who's responsible for what totally and
then I just think like in the first
couple of weeks or months with Ezekiel
Elliott if there's a screw-up and he's
only you know 12 carries for 35 yards
one game is that his fault cuz he didn't
know the plays is it you know a lack of
precision was there a lack of trust was
it just the game just happen to get away
from them I don't know like but it's
always that it's that extra level of
possible internal discord when you've
got a guy coming back not not there in
training camp
another roster note I am worried about
Devonta Freeman and the reason I'm
worried about Devonta Freeman is the
Atlanta Falcons kept six running backs
on their roster it's insane
Brian Hill Ito Smith a number of other
guys but I never want to judge too much
of watching people in preseason but I
watched Avante Freeman in preseason a
week three and I was not impressed at
all and maybe he just didn't want to get
hurt so we didn't try that hard
I didn't hit the l2 button but at the
same point when a team keeps six running
backs it's like when you keep four
quarterbacks you probably don't have one
you're waiting for them all so I'm a
little bit worried about Devonta Freeman
also a little bit selfish because I have
him on my LF GL team and my other
fantasy league and I passed on Leonard
fournette and whoa big offseason I can
say it cuz it happened a week ago our
own tie done put out this article
Leonard fournette locking himself in a
wyoming hotel for like a month and just
training and feeding off of the doubts
that people had of him last year and I
had Leonard fournette last year so I
feel like he's like channeling me but
it's a it's a little bit of that but I
am a little bit worried about Devon to
Freeman just keeping that money running
backs just makes me worried that they
have doubts about him when you say
Leonard fournette was in a Wyoming hotel
we've all worked out in a hotel gym it's
like to treadmill oh he Carol there was
no kidding okay he went to a facility
okay another thing that I saw just from
looking at rosters the Rams are really
not deep and I mentioned this before
number one they have nine rookies on
their team and you need to have nine
rookies on your team when you have an
Aaron Donald getting his contract Todd
Gurley Andrew Whitworth Marcus Peters a
key to leave Eric Weddle they are so
shallow that I'm telling you man like I
look at their roster and they need like
their number-one backup
at corner both safeties position outside
linebacker and middle linebacker is a
rookie and nose tackle so if you lose
any of those positions you got some kid
in there mm-hmm I'll still have Aaron
Donald as Defensive Player of the Year
though despite that they might like
double I have a hair I have miles
Garrett miles Garrett but I I mean Aaron
Donald's 1 or 2 Aaron Donald is
unblockable doesn't matter but my thing
is is it's great to have young guys for
the end of the year if they can get a
lot of experience but if they lose a
corner a safety they're relying on Clay
Matthews at outside linebacker and I'm
letting you know that Clay Matthews did
not look that great last year anyway I
have a lot of questions right now about
the Rams if they get injured and
remember what I told you they were the
healthiest team in the NFL the last
three years unsustainable so I picked
the Rams and they're locked in but the
way that it gets screwed up for me and
the Seahawks
if the Rams start getting bit by the
injury bug that's when it happens
so these are things that I'm going to
keep track of during the year if I start
seeing the injuries on the Rams I am
gonna sell a lot sooner than other
people just because of all the things
lining up right now men
well injuries there's different kinds of
injuries in different severity levels of
injury losing Todd Gurley and Cooper Cup
in the Super Bowl we don't know exactly
what was going on with Todd Gurley but
those even if it's just those two
injuries that's so massive in terms of
what you were planning on doing
offensively if you have six injuries two
guys I've never heard of I feel like
that's not nearly as bad as losing
Cooper cup and Todd Gurley see what's
interesting is I look at the opposite
the only position in which there's a
huge drop-off like statistically as
quarterback CJ Anderson was actually
outperforming Todd Gurley at the end of
the year last year but could Tiger Lee
have been even better if and in their
engine temperature form who knows I just
I look at with 53 men on a roster I look
at mass amounts of injuries as more
scary just because of what you were
talking before when I get someone
injured I bring in a new person and now
they have to get acclimated so it
creates all of this and now my issues
are mainly with the Rams defense that's
where I get concerned about what their
depth in terms of other teams Detroit
only kept seven defensive lineman which
is like fewest in the league which I'm
like really scary too when you factor in
that a lot of them have injury problems
heading into this season you look at
Mike Daniels he had a foot problem that
was so scary the Packers felt
comfortable leaving DeSean hand had a
left arm injury Trey flowers coming off
all seasons shoulder injury and they
only kept seven they just lost Austin
Bryant to the I our opposite David I
have talked on this podcast for a long
time about Minnesota having very shallow
d-line they kept 10 D lineman this year
very happy for Minnesota I am now gonna
talk and preview Packers bears I'm gonna
this is my first game breakdown game
Pick of the Year your gut instinct
having not done any research whatsoever
game is in Chicago make a pick go and
going bears ok you put me on the spot
that's my
good so I'm gonna do my breakdown David
if there's any nuggets that you go
that's interesting say so okay
I looked up sure Biscay I wanted to see
how he does in situations like this so
game is in Chicago true Biscay at home
23 touchdowns to ten interceptions on
the road eight to nine so just like
Jared Goff a lot worse laronne but he's
at home should be good for a chore
Biscay hold on though you said 23 to 10
then 8 to 9 so if he's actually throwing
fewer interceptions and far fewer
touchdowns that meet that implies to me
he's just doing different scheme stuff
that he's just throwing a lot like just
just not going for as much right like
the the same number of turnovers ok I
don't want to I don't want to
extrapolate that too much I understand
the ratio is different but the the sheer
number of turnovers is about the same
yes
so September try Biscay in September is
3 and 1 with a quarterback rating over a
hundred the other three months in which
the Bears play his quarterback rating is
in the 80s so last year started off very
strong we'll see if that continues not
enough of a sample size to bet on he is
three and two and night games with a 5
to 8 touchdown interception ratio and he
is one in two against the Packers
just little things to be interested in
Green Bay has owned this rivalry lately
winning 15 of the last 18 games against
Chicago since 2010 I the the thing
that's most interesting to me is in the
NFL season opener the home team they've
been doing it for 17 years the home team
is 14 and 3 straight up so in the NFL
season opener that happens on this
Thursday night to kick off the year the
home team is 14 and 3 last time there
was a loss your Patriots lost to the
Chiefs when Kareem hunt exploded over
three well two or three years ago when
the Packers are on offense is when I
have the most questions I don't know
what this LeFleur offense is going to be
like with Aaron Rodgers I don't know
what they haven't shown I don't know
what it's going to be new Bears defense
no Vic Fangio a lot of questions on beau
the ball there but I have to imagine the
Bears have almost every single guy back
from last year they swapped out Adrian a
most for haha Knicks will Aaron Rodgers
attack Clinton Dix his former teammate
with Green Bay I think that the Packers
old line will do well against the Bears
defensive line but this is the Bears
defense and when you have a new
offensive coordinator and a new coach
for the Packers my gut feeling is that
Matt Lafleur might be a little
overwhelmed on the sidelines I can't
speak to the emotions that they're gonna
have on the sidelines I just get that
feeling this is like that first game in
a World Cup did you know that the host
country always plays in the first game
of every World Cup and they have never
lost in any World Cup
whether it's like Brazil hosting or
South Africa hosting the host team has
never actually lost the first team I
feel like Bears hosting Packers for the
100th season of the NFL just feels like
this momentous occasion and Chicago just
can't let that sound guys who's number
14 and three to the home team I think
the Bears have a slightly better defense
and the Packers of a slightly better
office that's been charged offense let
me finish yuck the Bears offense the one
thing that I really am paying attention
to right now from a roster perspective
is the Green Bay Packers are so
decimated at linebacker Oren Burks tore
his PEC in the preseason they lost
Curtis Bolton they just traded for BJ
Goodson from the Giants like they just
made that trade two days ago and he's
starting next to Blake Martinez so I
look at the Packers defense and they
already released Mike Daniels earlier
this offseason and I'm going is there a
worse team in the NFL to face with a
depleted linebacking core than the Bears
David Montgomery tarik Cohen lots of
motion the Bears have cordarrelle
Patterson
all over the place then you have Anthony
Miller that can do a lot of sweeps
Taylor Gabriel this is an a Bears
offense that has been hearing all
offseason
about how they are going to be taking a
step back and questions about try Biscay
I think they are going to come out there
and do a ton of sweeps a ton of motion
and
fuse the hell out of a linebacker that
just got to the Packers a day ago Alan
Robinson has a huge size advantage
sanjay year Alexander the corner really
my biggest question for the Bears is
eddie Panero because it's going to come
down to the kicker
it always does the Bears are favored by
three I am actually gonna pick the Bears
to cover this one 24 to 20 I just think
that Aaron Rodgers is gonna make plays
it's gonna be close but I think that the
Bears get it done because they're at
home and I think that they're able to to
handle the spread with three I got them
at 24 to 20 that's such an NFC North
score 24 20 21 17 just feels like it's
like it's just like two teams that are
just crashing into each other and when
one team wins it by you know a missed
field goal at the end of the second
quarter ends up mattering at the end so
we'll wait and see what Warren sharp has
to say about my pick when he gets in
here we are gonna record in that on
Thursday it's gonna come out Friday I
talked to him today for like 20 minutes
and we are both so excited to like
really dive into all the lines and all
the Nuggets that he has I see guys the
gambling show this year as an evolution
of what we've done before I think the
last few years it's been a lot of fun
and me and Sims competing this year I
really see it as Warren making us all a
lot smarter Warren making us a lot of
money me doing my same old gut bet stuff
and Warren going hey I'm a little bit
worried about this this of this and
we're gonna be betting I'm gonna be
making my five Super contest picks that
come out every Friday if you guys want a
line with that because I know look we've
heard this from cretton I'm gonna I'm
gonna call crack live and and give him
my proxy bets and get his raw reactions
right away from who I'm taking he think
you'll just like start laughing it so he
might be like I'm actually going
opposite on those which could be a lot
of fun and then I'm hoping to announce
to you guys next week
not even announce have the dude in here
next week of who it's gonna be
to recap week one and all that it should
be a blast but to kind of get back to
where I was in the very beginning ditch
the play book comes out Wednesday at
11:00 it's gonna be with Mohamed Sanu
how many quarterbacks he can throw it
further than if you see the tweet my
tweet when I put it out respond to what
was it again it was I liked this episode
so much that I loved this episode so
much that and the funniest ones are
getting retweeted 33 percent you are the
[ __ ] ezel my guy Vincent with the art
appreciate you guys Inger you're the
[ __ ] man thank you so much for your
hard work on [ __ ] the playbook on Oprah
so excited for them to come out week to
monster week for monster very excited
for you guys to see those episodes until
then for Engler if you have a sharp
knife in the kitchen it does what you
want it to do you have a dull knife it
does what it wants to do I am the lef
koe man and we will holla holla holla at
you later enjoy the game Thursday night
guys
see ya
[Music]